so awesome to be here with you again
last time we got up here
we got a chance to show you savathun the
witch queen and her majestic throne
world
since then it's been a wild year for
destiny you returned to the original
loot cave to reclaim the fabled galler
horn then
you exercised an ancient evil
from a hive queen
so you could put it inside a grenade
launcher
and now you've been spending the past
few weeks cleansing a derelict leviathan
from its twisted nightmares in fact the
last year has been the best year we've
ever had in the destiny community i hope
you can feel it as well
and seeing this kind of reaction from
our community it's both humbling and
inspiring because our team here at
bungie we're not just developers we're
also guardians we're trying to build
what we'd love to play in destiny and
that's what brought each one of us here
brought us not only to bungie but also
brought all of us to this final showdown
between light and darkness
so
without further ado
this
is the beginning
of the end this
is
lightfall they see this glorious end
they will come for us
it's who they are
let them come and see
oh shame
reveal
what they do then
[Music]
that
is
are we free
i've seen that thing a hundred times now
and every time i see it i still kind of
get goosebumps instantly i had chills
it's all here it's all happening now
things are finally coming to a head
thematically we really have been honing
in on that kind of bombastic big set
piece approach it's gonna be over the
top action adrenaline pumping like the
whole time
this is really kicking off the
conclusion to the light and dark saga
where we finally face down this foe that
we've been anticipating facing for so
long it's pushing it to 11.
we've been hinting at this malicious
force in the darkness that's been our
enemy behind a lot of our conflicts we
revealed that enemy we put a name on it
and put a face on it and that enemy is
the witness
and the witness is coming with its newly
empowered disciple callus kallus is
really crash landing with a new and more
powerful army than ever before
they've got new powers they've got new
armor they've got tormentors to join
their ranks that are going to be bigger
and better enemies than we've ever faced
callus is taking that army that he's
bringing with him to be the harbinger of
the witness's doom
this is such a pivotal moment for
destiny everyone is coming to have a
last stand with kallus and the witness
to really avoid the next collapse
something that we've been trying to
avoid ever since destiny won
we see in the trailer that we're headed
to neptune and on neptune there's been
this hidden city called neomuna where an
alternate version of humanity has been
blooming since the collapse
neo muna is the capital city of neptune
it's a giant metropolis that we were
completely unaware existed until now
what's interesting and exciting to me
about this place is that it's pristine
it's new it's not like a lot of the
places that we've explored previously in
destiny exploring that space is very
very cool there's so much new stuff to
discover in nyomuna and in neptune and
also i saw some new characters there i'm
really excited to get to know cloud
striders and their story
[Music]
cloud striders can be compared to
guardians they're both protectors of a
civilization that's potentially under
threat but guardians were chosen
it's their duty to protect humanity
cloud striders have chosen to protect
their people there's like an awesome
opportunity for the guardians to learn
from the cloud striders and their way of
living and their philosophy of life so
we've got the newness of that city the
newness of the cloud striders that we've
never been aware of and then of course
you get a glimpse of
this green
energy
i wonder what that is
strand is the new darkness power that we
discover here something that's unique
about strand unlike any of these other
powers we've ever had before
when you play through lightfall you are
discovering this power for the first
time no one in the universe ever in the
history of destiny has used strand
before this is the guardian discovering
darkness on their own
and learning how to shape it and
manipulate it and use it against callus
and his forces and you know have fun in
the new urban environment of mia luna
you are really going to have to prepare
yourself for a wild ride we just got a
glimpse of our new destination mio muna
our new foe callus and the shadow legion
paired with the witness and
a very brief glimpse at strand but
that's just barely scratching the
surface of what this release has to
offer right like what we've just seen in
that trailer is just the tip of the
iceberg and we've got a whole lot more
we're excited to show you coming up
last year we wanted to return to our
studio's roots in creating some of the
best shooter campaigns in the industry
that's been our legacy since halo and we
tried to push that front and center in
the witch queen and it's about more than
just guns but creating an adventure in a
handcrafted world full of surprises
then we added the legendary campaign
option because great combat needs to
challenge you to test your thumb skill
your tactics and your build crafting and
we heard loud and clear that you want
more of that
in fact two out of every three players
that completed the witch queen campaign
did it on legendary you tested yourself
against the witch queen interlucent hive
and rose to that challenge
and then you let us know it was one of
the best shooter experiences that we've
ever made so with lightfall we want to
push that even further we want to give
you the best bungee action experience
that we can create with the brand new
lightfall campaign
lightfall is going to change the way
that our players move fight and explore
everywhere in destiny neptune is this
fantastic destination the capital city
of neomuna is a really fun place to
explore and it's this bright neon
metropolis there's a harbor office
buildings an arcade
this is a city that we've made and using
strand to traverse through it and
explore it it's going to be so exciting
there's some places that once you whip
out that grappling hook ooh you're going
to be able to explore and get to places
that you couldn't before look at that up
there i wonder if i can grapple to there
i'm going to be a kid in a candy store
it's not a city that is collapsed it is
a city that has lived through the
collapse neptune now has to deal with
the cloak being pulled back and then
being revealed to the world and are now
central of the conflict callus has taken
his capital ship and just like planted
it right down in part of the city and
it's cabal occupied territory it's a
city under siege you've got this
infiltrator vibe at times where you feel
like a tactical team going into a
skyscraper you're dealing with cabal
roadblocks and patrols all throughout
the city
the shadow legion they provide that like
characteristic cabal
brute strength they're all about like
volatility and power and they've been
enhanced now by pyramid technology they
have these suppression devices that can
take away some of your super take away
some of your abilities and then they
fight alongside these terrifying new
pyramid units called tormentors
as part of his discipleship to the
witness
callus has been upgraded and so the
tormentors that they brought in are
these impossibly huge unstoppable
behemoths they wield scythes they can
attack from a distance they can bring
you in close they can drain your very
life force from you they are basically
embodiments of terror it's like a boss
character within the battlefield your
stomach drops you're like okay i'm
playing through i'm having fun popping
heads doing this thing and then boom
there it is
we've got all the new stuff going into
the game strand tormentors shadow legion
a cool new environment these are all a
great setting for a new legendary
campaign and we're still making sure
that we go through and we tweak and tune
and we balance the encounters to have
that right challenging level of
difficulty for players the legendary
campaign was a huge hit coming out of
the witch queen it was the first time we
had done that sort of elected difficulty
where you could really test your skill
and test your power and so we're going
to bring that back for light fall of
course you're still going to have that
high reward tier and we still want to
make sure that you get that inside track
towards being raid ready
everyone back in the studio is so hard
at work on lightfall putting in the
details and making this whole release
come alive and continue to surprise and
delight players i am so excited to get
this out lightfall is unlike anything
players have seen before in destiny and
it's another step that sends you
hurdling to the conclusion of the light
and dark saga
[Applause]
come on amazing i'm super excited to
dive into strand and talk about all the
new stuff that we just saw
strand like stasis is a power from the
darkness unlike our light abilities
which are all about creation darkness is
more about consciousness
strand is psychic energy that forms this
extra dimension or this sort of matrix
that connects everything together
connects all living beings and all minds
and you the guardian is sort of gaining
the knowledge and gaining the power to
peer into this alternate psychic
universe and begin to pull at these
threads and tug at these wires that are
connecting all these living beings
when guardians learn how to use strand
it's almost like this third eye opens up
it's about peeling back the curtain of
reality taking those connections and
then weaving them into new objects
yeah and it's pretty cool to see them
come together like it's always been
there and now that we can tap into it we
can use it for our benefit whether it's
through movement or
through damage
strand has a grappling hook since you're
seeing into this cosmic web you are able
to grapple at any point because the
cosmic web exists everywhere
even if there's not an object there it
will hook on to that web and pull you
forward it's just taking that idea to
the next level putting that uh destiny
spin on it
the grappling hook initially started as
part of the hunter's kit right they're
all about fluid movement rapidly
traversing space and being very agile
but as we were developing it's like oh
man it's this feels like it's too much
fun to just keep it to one class right
so we made the call to expand the super
cool new ability across all three
classes
on the design side we wanted to come up
with how each of the classes interpreted
this additional psychic dimension like
in their own way right
so the warlock they're the telekinetic
master of strand so they're going to be
able to telepathically reach into the
strand dimension pull matter out and
weave it into this big barrage of these
strand missiles
wherever they land these missiles are
actually going to unravel sort of
re-weave themselves into a new form
with the titan you're able to weave
these claws and do an area of damage
around you spinning and splashing
the super i think i'm most excited for
is the hunter rope dart super
the hunter does a flip and weaves these
strands into this rope dart and is
swinging it as they're kind of moving
around
the first time i saw that even in its
kind of like rough state it just blew my
mind
we've learned a lot from creating our
other subclasses and we've taken those
learnings about combat about movement
about build crafting we put that all
into strand and i'm so excited to see
where players take it once it's out
there in the wild
destiny is a game that gets even better
when you play with your friends we want
to create communities that are welcoming
inclusive and let you bring your old
friends and make new ones
and since last year over 5 million new
guardians have joined our ranks we
believe that there are still millions
more of your friends that would love to
play destiny with you and the things
that you want to see us improve in
destiny are also exactly what's going to
make it easier to convince your friends
to come and check out the game
it should be easier to create custom
incredible builds easier to find people
to play with
easier to swap from being that boss
melting storm chaser wielding falling
star juggernaut
right into that ultimate ye hine dead
man's tail shooting sightings rampart
crushing sentinel
and if none of what joe just said makes
sense to you we want to fix that too
because it's not about removing the
depth that makes destiny so great it's
instead about allowing everyone to dive
deeper with ease
the changes we're making to make destiny
easier to come into changes to how you
build your characters changes to how you
see what there is to do and what there
is to accomplish
and in the year ahead we're actually
making it easier to form groups in
destiny so you can go and do some of the
greatest content that destiny has to
offer all the teams are working together
to build this experience and so that's
what's really exciting we keep on
hearing from players like
hey unless i have a friend to play with
i don't know what to do and so we're
trying to give them is like hey here's a
path to follow guardian ranks are this
like basically like a knowledge ladder
we actually progressed you through 11
ranks and it's really like heavily
focusing on like exposing players to all
the systems of destiny at some point the
story about you as a guardian involves
other guardians and what they think
about you that is just a whole new
dimension of your journey through
destiny that we've never really explored
before when you show up in the tower and
you see that person who's at one of the
highest ranks you're going to know that
you're looking at a player who's
actually really demonstrated mastery of
many of the different activities in
destiny
not just from
our perspective but from the perspective
of other players some of the higher
guardian ranks will actually be
asking for you to step up to actually
rise to the occasion and prove
to other guardians
that you are a strong player and a
strong leader
a lot of people have groups that they
already play with but this will really
provide people the opportunity to be
recognized for
helping other people learn the game but
also provide more people to play with on
a regular basis in the year of lightfall
we're going to actually be investing in
building a looking for group system in
destiny itself you'll be able to look
for other players you'll be able to find
groups that are looking for players i'm
so excited about being able to form
groups in the next coming year because
it can be really hard to
get through some of the hard content
solo and making it so much easier to
find people to play with is just going
to make getting into destiny and doing
awesome content so much easier yeah and
they'll be able to say this is a player
who i can trust to lead me through the
new raid i want to join their group or
they can say these are players who are
new to the activity i want to take them
for that first raid because that'll be a
great experience for them and a valuable
experience for me as a leader it's
really going to help players come
together and understand each other
better when they've never met before
it's going to make the game so much more
social and i think that it's going to
really make destiny players feel like
they're on one team
so commendations is a feature that
you'll experience towards the end of an
activity so you end the activity now and
you get to see the screen that has all
the people you played with you can click
on one of the guardians and choose what
experience you had with them so like
were they a good team player were they
fun to play with
there's no better way to actually show
how good a person is as a teammate or as
a leader than to have other players say
this person's a great teammate this
person's a great leader it's really a
system that's designed to
let players show appreciation for each
other also using the commendation system
people are going to be able to say like
hey this person as a good leader and and
looking at the guardian rank system they
have a lot of experience it's going to
be oh that's the person i want to help
me get through this hard content that
i've been struggling with social games
like destiny give you an opportunity to
like really connect with other people
and do things together and get to know
each other and
with a system like lfg you're making it
so that more people can get that
experience started than ever before
both the loadout screen and the mod
manager are completely new features the
mod manager is meant to make build
construction destiny a lot easier we all
love our fashion game fashion game is
amazing and so we're gonna take what we
did for the fashion game and we're
bringing it to the build craft game
there's gonna be one screen where you
can go to and do your entire loadout for
your character it's gonna be amazing so
you'll be able to save the build that
you've put together as a loadout and
then switch between those things as
you're going from activity to activity
yeah i feel like with the new released
destiny and the accommodation system
mixed with guardian ranks we're giving
players even new aspirations it isn't
going to be just about power level it
won't just be about gear it's also going
to be about that guardian rank it's
going to be about those commendations
it's all the ways that we're bringing
players together
[Music]
so today we are also launching a brand
new season of destiny 2.
and as we've evolved our seasons over
the years we've learned a lot and i
think we've been able to deliver some
amazing character moments and events for
the community we're long past the era of
content droughts instead
there are exciting story and events
happening in destiny almost every week
year round and we're not slowing down
each season we want to keep raising the
bar for narrative experiences in any
live game we want to keep pushing to
create unexpected adventures that'll
make every season of destiny unique and
we want to keep listening and learning
from you the destiny community so that
we can create the strongest seasons of
any live service because the witness is
coming
and if we want to survive we need a crew
we need to enrich our defenses
if you're feeling surly maybe even loot
our enemies we may even need to find a
captain to join us on our next adventure
in the season of plunder
what is the human word
pirates
the full vanguard should be rallied to
deal with these
outlaws
well anchors away
now go show those pirates what happens
when they crush spider heads
barge
you got the goods guardian
sorry getting a little swept up in all
this adventuring
[Music]
what are you most excited about for
season of plunder
pirates
this season we said what if we just go
to the stars and dig up buried treasure
we are unearthing a lot of mysteries and
secrets we're swashbuckling onto enemy
spaceships and then we're also learning
a lot of things about some of our
favorite characters we're gonna have an
adventure this season
seasonal plunder kicks off with aramus
being freed from her icy prison she's
collected old fallen crews of pirates
and rogue cabal together in order to
hunt down mysterious relics and
treasures it's time to meet your end so
guardians are tasked with stopping
aramis from collecting these relics and
in order to do that you have to create
your own crew of shady dealers and back
room brokers drifter myth racks idaho
and spider are going to be helping you
anchors away
ready when you are captain that's the
beginning of season of plunder what
you're going to be doing is forming a
pirate crew of your own you're going to
fill it with different crew members that
you can recruit over the course of the
season
drifter is going to toss you the keys to
your personal catch then you're just
going to set out into the stars and do
cool pirate stuff
so excited
this season we have multiple brand new
activities coming that will really give
you a sense of being on a pirate
adventure one of the mainstays of this
season is a new six player offensive
called catch crash
when i saw the concept for the catch
with the big main sails on i just said
oh my god this will be a fun season
just like seeing catch crash through the
different iterations like fighting on
the deck of the ship you get to become
your own ammunition and
launch yourself from a cannon to the
other ship and you are the weapon so
you're gonna go mess them up
the second big activity we have coming
this season is called expedition
you're gonna be guiding a massive drill
that's looking for this buried hidden
pirate treasure and you're gonna have to
be fending off of all these pirate crews
trying to protect their hordes
and then our final new activity coming
this season is what we're calling pirate
hideouts we have so many like different
little maps that you can piece together
fragments of this season and that leads
you to the lair of the pirate lord right
their hideout these are their caves
where they're hoarding all of their
amazing treasures and their mysterious
relics these relics are mysterious
objects of dark power and they're all
over the system we don't know exactly
what it is they do yet but if aramis is
trying to collect them it's nothing good
taking the opportunity to line the arc
3.0 update with the fall and it just
went up working out perfectly because
you've got all the simple arc weaponry
and the arc shielded captains it feels
right with that release almost like we
planned it arc is a damage type that's
about proximity right it's about going
fast up into your enemies faces and like
deleting them it's the the damage type
for people that want to hold w you don't
want to retreat unbridled aggression to
the max
hunter is really about close range
action being fluid and dynamic and agile
evasive so we're going to give our
country a new super uh we call it
gathering storm where you summon your
staff like twirl above your head and
then launch it out and then it will
embed into the ground or into like
bosses or mini bosses or champions and
jolt them like a big lightning strike
will strike the staff and overcharge it
and while that staff is overcharged
it'll start tesla coiling little
lightning bolts out at nearby enemies
warlock is kind of this elemental
conduit you are a class that will turn
yourself into lightning you will create
things out of lightning previously you
know we had this exotic armor piece
called getaway artist where you consume
your grenade it'll make a what we call a
sentient ark soul that fires faster and
then does more damage result so we
decided to roll that into base arc soul
behavior anytime you are amplified any
arc soul you have from any source
will become the supercharged version
that will fire off just rapid fire bolts
titan's about being this unstoppable
freight train it's about this constant
movement so we gave titans a new
movement option something that we felt
like is going to be competitive in this
new environment of air dodges and air
slams that's a new ability called
thruster it's all in first person it's
all very much in the heat of the moment
you see it happen it's whole property is
like rush down or getaway it's a
movement tool to the max
there's going to be this new melee
ability called thunderclap which is like
an amazing thing where he like charges
his fist off super flashy it's our first
ever charge melee so you hold down the
button and as that [ __ ] back and
charges up you'll end up doing more
damage and getting a little bit more
range
and speaking of like the whole goal of
deleting things i believe in pvp of full
charges on one shot kill it is oh yeah
it's it's a little skillful to like pull
off because you're gonna have to really
read your opponent here
the whole through line with arc is like
it really isn't that complicated it's
move fast
hit hard
and stay alive
what i'm most excited about in season of
plunder is that this is really a season
that has a sense of adventure you're
you're exploring the system you're
looking for pirate treasure pirate
relics you're seeing the world evolve in
a way we haven't done before i love that
with the activities in the season like
we just leaned really hard into the
pirate fancies i love that we have your
own catch i love that you're tracking
down buried treasure and then going
after the pirate leaders in their caves
the interesting thing about destiny is
we're not just a fantasy game or a
sci-fi game we're kind of a blend of
both and we take inspiration when we say
pirates it's old world pirates that you
would see traditionally back in the 17th
and 1800s we have like a flintlock
pistol we have an exotic fusion rifle
that plays different than fusion rifles
you've ever seen before it's just like
end to end just really leaning into that
spirit of like the pirate adventure and
let's also make it so that new players
coming in can actually jump in and get
started the gift of the thunder gods is
a starter kit it's a set of armor it's a
thunderlord exotic weapon
so jump in join your friends set sail
become the captain and build your crew
today in destiny
so
man it is so awesome seeing king's fall
return to destiny yeah actually kings
fall was the first thing i got to work
on at bungie and i'm thrilled that a
whole new generation of guardians will
get to experience this refreshed and
reloaded showdown with the taken king
so we've shown you lightfall we've shown
you the new damage type strand we've
shown you some of the deeper changes to
the game that we're going to be making
throughout the next year but we have one
more thing that we are excited to
announce today
destiny is coming to the epic game store
today
epic has been an absolutely fabulous
partner to work with they love destiny
and we are just huge fans of what
they've been doing in the social game
space when we first started working with
epic we sat down and talked about the
impact their games have had on us and
they had a bunch of the same stories for
us
they shared stories about playing the
vault of glass and how much they enjoy
the social experiences in destiny
and i got to talk about the summer of
fortnite chapter one season five when my
whole family was laser focused taking
turns in the island to unlock drift in
addition to launching all of destiny 2
on the epic game store today
for the next week if you download the
game on epic we will give you the 30th
anniversary for free
if you haven't earned your gala horn yet
or you haven't played the grasp dungeon
come to the epic game store and you can
jump in for free
we want to welcome all these new
guardians with a celebration
one that stretches a little further
than the last city
[Applause]
a few years ago we shared our plans for
the light and darkness saga
this journey
years in the making is coming to an end
since we started charting our own course
we've been building this story
across five years of expansions since
the first pyramid ship emerged in shadow
keep when we first spoke to the darkness
then
across beyond light
the witch queen and coming up in
lightfall in the final shape
we're building towards a climactic
collision between the powers of light
and dark
we've also been working on the destiny
engine behind the scenes
preparing our technology and our game to
last for many many years to come
because destiny 2 is not going anywhere
and neither are your expansions
we want this story since we first
communed with the darkness on the moon
to be fully playable start to finish
and we're happy to announce today that
we are not planning to sunset any more
expansions
we want the destiny universe to grow and
we're going to continue to do everything
that we can behind the scenes to keep
that possible within our game engine
but enough about the distant future
let's talk about today
the best day all year to jump into
destiny yes
because if you're looking to catch up
right now all expansions are free to
play for this entire week on every
platform
for everyone right now season of plunder
is live and the helm's got a set of
supercharged art gear
for anyone looking to catch up on the
fun destiny is live on the epic game
store you can download it for free and
you can get the 30th anniversary pack as
your welcome gift and if you liked what
you saw about the future
right now pre-orders for lightfall are
live on all platforms and anyone who
purchases the annual pass gets the
exotic auto rifle quick silver storm
today today is a perfect day to play
destiny
so we'll see you in game
[Music]
when they see this glorious end
what is the human word
pirates
so
let them come and
what they do then
that
is who they are